[Music]
so in this lesson we're going to talk
about adobe
media encoder which you probably have if
you have after effects
on your computer if you don't have it
installed
i do love it and it's a very powerful
program
so how do you use adobe media encoder to
render it's really simple
all you do is go into your composition
that you want to render
or
same up in here project window and go to
composition
add to adobe media encoder queue
and down here
same thing add to adobe media encoder
queue we'll click that and what happens
is is media encoder automatically
launches if it's not already open
it will take a few seconds or a minute
and launch itself and
there it is so once media encoder is
open
we have um a lot of presets to choose
from here so the first one here
we've got the quicktime
we've got
h.264
mpeg-4
uh tiff
a lot of different things animated gifs
gifs
uh
hevc which i'm a huge fan of right now
so from here we can pick a preset and
that preset
uh can then be uh changed even further
by going into
here and
changing uh different settings within it
so
this preset is match source high bit
rate there's all these presets just for
h.264 by itself if i want to go ahead
and change the uh the wrapper to
quicktime
here's my preset for that uh it pulls in
uh presets that i've already created for
a media encoder
as well as ones that are preset within
the program so uh like for this one i
may pick prores four 422
hq and i can click that and i can see
here an example
of my render and it shows me how it's
going to look here
and i can also adjust in and out points
here if i want to do that i can scale
the size
to fit in the window i can make it 100
whatever i need it to be at
scale to fit stretch to fill all those
good things over here we can select
things like export video export audio if
we don't want audio on this because
there's no audio attached i can turn
that off here
i'll put the name here i tell it where
to save the file here
going down into
inside the presets this is where i can
also pick different codecs if i want to
pick different codecs
i can scroll down within this
i can match the source of the quality i
can change it here if i need to i can
change the size here if i need to i have
to uncheck this box i can keep it
constrained or i can put in custom sizes
here if needed i can uncheck this i can
change the frame right here everything
is check marked as kind of like a
precaution so that you don't go in and
start changing things you can change the
bit depth here
you can render at maximum depth here
advanced settings i hardly ever use
bitrate settings i'm not going to mess
with too much again use maximum render
quality
and you can also put made it method data
into this as well
which if you're into metadata that's
very powerful stuff
we also have things like effects where
you can apply lumetri
lut effects name overlays things that i
rarely ever use
you may use them
audio this is turned off there's nothing
here because i've turned it off up here
so if i enable this
boom there's all the audio
[Music]
abilities
things i can change customize
you can change the sample rate you can
change the sample size
the audio codec here says uncompressed
because we are
using a
higher format
prores
file so if we were to change this to
something like h.264
uh now inside of our audio you can see i
can change from aac to mpeg4 i can
change uh the different codecs
things like that change the quality
change the bit rate
all that good stuff so a lot of
customization can happen here in a media
encoder
that is much more challenging to do
inside of after effects or not even
possible at all it just depends
now i will tell you actually before i
finish this out
multiplexer captions if you're using
captions and then publish this is a
really cool option if you want to use
this where you can actually
click on something like your facebook
account
and you can log in and it'll publish
right to that account
same with some of the other social media
platforms ftp
twitter
vimeo
youtube
i actually need to use more of this
because it's a very powerful tool uh it
makes it much easier to post
so if you're in here and you've kind of
played around with some of the different
settings you've decided that you're
going to change some of these settings
around and you're going to notice up
here that it now says custom for preset
and this is when you can go in and you
can say
i want to
save this preset
or you want to import a preset so you
can save a preset
and you can do that by just
naming it
test preset or whatever you're going to
call it
if you've added effects you can save
those here as well if you've added
publishing settings you can save those
as well and then just click ok
and there it is test preset and it's
going to load up in the top part of the
presets here
and you can access this at any time and
it's an easy to use preset system
so those are the options i am going to
tell you that
i've done a lot of testing
rendering between
straight up after effects
or straight out of media encoder and
overall it's much quicker it seems to be
to render straight out of after effects
by quite a bit
just depending on the project file
sometimes it's
10 to 20 percent faster to render out
after effects sometimes it's 50 or more
faster to render straight out after
effects now the advantage
of going straight to media encoder and
why i
will use it is because i have set up
presets
for social media platforms
uh or motion science in general
presets i have made to publish to that
platform and for me to render
directly out of after effects isn't
possible
to do that so for instance when i post
on instagram right now i actually use
this hevc h.265
uh format to post to instagram
um when i post things to the platform
for motion science i use a codec i've
called created called new kajabi because
that's the platform i use so it just
depends if i was to render straight out
of after effects
for a social media platform i would then
have to bring that file into media
encoder
and
render it here inside of media encoder
and that is
to me more time consuming than putting
an extra 20
time into
rendering directly to midi encoder and
it's spitting out one file
versus an uncompressed file and then a
compressed file so hopefully that makes
sense to you
so something else that's really cool
about media encoder is like i can
duplicate
this setup so if i want to render out an
h264
at a match source high bit rate i also
want to render out a hevc file
match source i also want to duplicate it
again
which i can hit command d on the
keyboard or i could duplicate here i
could render out let's say a quick time
here and i want it to
be
prores 422 hq but i also want it to not
have audio
and what i can do now is i can hit start
and it's going to start just encoding
this first file as soon as this one's
done it's going to move into the next
file and so on and so forth and it just
moves down the list as i add
renders to this it'll just pick up
where it's at and just continue
rendering so it's pretty powerful in
that sense okay so something else that's
very powerful about media encoder is
something called watch folders
and what are watch folders they're
really awesome you click on this little
tab right here to pull it up if you
don't see it you need to make sure that
you have watch folders enabled here on
the window and once you have it all you
do is go over here to the plus sign and
click add and you're going to go to your
folder that's called
the watch folder mine's called a render
folder there it is all you have to do is
select that folder
and then once you have this folder
selected you're going to set up a preset
that how you want
items within this folder to render so i
want them to render h264 i want them to
match source high bitrate and all that
means is is that the the bit rate is
going to be very high it's going to use
a software encoder uh bbr one pass i
could change any of this if i wanted to
increase
things here i could set it all up if i
wanted to be two pass sure maybe we'll
do that instead
uh you can make all the changes just
like you do in the normal media encoder
you're gonna make all those changes here
you're gonna set it up
and what happens now is anytime
something is dropped into this
watch folder it's going to automatically
start rendering i'm on a mac here and
i've got my render folder pulled up and
here's the folder and
there's nothing inside these folders yet
but this is the folder i told
media encoder to watch as my render
folder and this folder could be called
anything you want to call it i just call
it render folder so for this instance i
want to take another render i have which
is a quicktime movie right here and this
is just people on stage from a concert
and it's 120 megabytes it's a quicktime
movie i want it to be
rendered in my h264 so all i have to do
is
drop this over here
inside of my folder and watch what
happens here in media encoder without me
doing anything
it's going to automatically
pick up on that and start rendering
pretty cool stuff
so again i could take
this renderer i could take this render
and i'm just dropping those in there
and same thing they're going to
immediately start rendering here
uh inside the washroom there they go so
now they're rendering it's going to see
two different files so now a second one
is going to pop up and start rendering
as well
um as soon as this one finishes
and they're being rendered to h.264s
if at any time i want to change this
it's really easy to do
let's go back up here and
change that preset so now it's running
the second one as soon as it renders
them you'll notice that it moves it out
of here so this one's going to finish
it's going to move out now it's gone and
it moves it into a source folder here so
here are
my footage pieces that were dropped in
put nicely away in here
and here's my output and these are all
my h264s they're ready to go for
whatever i need to use them for
so
i want to show you one other very
powerful feature of this watch folder
and that is the ability to render after
effects project files as well
so how does this work so here is the
project file i was working on it's
called advanced rendering it's the name
of the lesson and here is that project
file right here okay so all i have to do
is
take this project file into the render
folder just like a quicktime was dropped
in here all i have to do is drop this
project file in here so what i like to
do is actually alter option click and
drag and it makes a copy
and boom there it is inside and it's
ready to render but what you're going to
notice is is that nothing actually
renders here
in my media encoder and i'm going to
tell you why uh it's because
any composition that you want to render
from your after effects project file has
to be
in the root
file structure of the project window so
you can see the comps are all inside of
a folder here and it's kind of a safety
net so that means that
if i want to only render
this comp it needs to be out here by
itself if i want to render
both of these comps
then they need to both be outside of
here and it's going to render both of
these comps so what we're going to do is
we're going to
save this project file
and we're going to go back here
and the project file has
updated itself so i'm just going to
take it and copy and it's going to say
do you want to replace it
yes i do
and you're going to see right here on
the media encoder it's going to pop up
here in just a second when it sees that
project file and it's going to start
rendering
the compositions and there it goes so
it's going to render the first
composition
which is probably
actually going to go day for night so
it's going in alphabetical order
and then as soon as day for night has
rendered it's going to render
the proxy
okay so both
compositions were rendered and you can
see
here in source
it's got the project put in there and
then it's got the proxy and the day for
night so day for night this is that
composition and proxy is that's that
composition
both rendered uh super powerful so any
time you drop a render
a quick time or a after effects project
file into this
render folder it's going to uh just as
long as media encoder is open it's going
to see that and it's going to start
rendering it so that's what i've got for
you for
advanced rendering media encoder
hope you learned something new
[Music]
you